hier draußen ist doch richtig windig da
haut's uns alles um
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es mal wieder seit langem und
ich glaube es ist schon lange her dass
es hier pizza gab eine pizza und zwar
wurde ich da inspiriert von einem mädels
ausflug in münchen der ich war neulich
mit der ana in münchen und da mal was
essen gehen und dann hat sie songs
dieses kleines italienisches restaurant
ausgesucht und ihr kennt wahrscheinlich
alle dieser restaurants die sowieso
spezieller sind gerd die netze die nicht
so mainstream sind da geht es um so eine
handgeschriebene karte und das sah echt
süß aus aber ich muss sagen so auf den
ersten blick habe ich auf der karte erst
mal gar nichts gefunden weil so alles
gefühlt so ein bisschen speziell war
bisher dass trüffel und dafür bisschen
speziell und danach mal gedacht sei ich
finde man hier so gar nichts zum essen
und dann war aber so der anstand
vorkommen lasst uns irgendwas gestellt
und erst mal dass unternehmer und dann
haben wir uns da so eine pizza
ausgesucht eine weiße pizza und es war
so eine ganz dünne knusprige mit trüffel
butter und käse und dann warte ich so
lecker und dann haben wir uns gerade
nochmal zwei gestellt ich muss auch
sagen die besitzerin war erst so ein
bisschen weil wir gesagt haben wir
nehmen die eine und die teilen wir uns
und sie war schon wissen ich glaube sie
war bisher wie kann ich da sagen ana
bis juni enttäuscht dass wir quasi nur
eine dünne halbe knusprige pizza
zusammengestellt aber wie gesagt wir
haben es danach noch mal zwei ganze
bestellt und zwar richtig lecker und das
hat mich jetzt dazu inspiriert zu sagen
ich mache heute eine weise pizza wir
machen 100 jahren kamen deswegen erst
mal meinen standard grundrezept für den
pizzateig und dann gehts aber gleich
noch draußen denn das wetter ist perfekt
und ich muss sagen bei so einem wetter
will ich dann auch nicht in der küche
stehen da steht dann lieber draußen im
garten und kocht dort also für den
hefeteig verwende ich zehn gramm hefe
zwei esslöffel zucker 450 gramm warmes
wasser 900 gramm mehl weizen oder dinkel
hier habe ich zwei teelöffel salz und
etwas olivenöl anfang habe ich schon
kurze bisschen schlecht gefühlt als ich
so wenig gestellt habe aber dann gemacht
und war echt und dann war voll hat und
es war richtig richtig lecker also habe
ich jetzt die hefe drin zucker und
wasser und dann gebt ihr einfach mehl
salz und öl dazu knetet den teig etwa
zehn minuten lang schön geschmeidig
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt super aus und
normalerweise back ich da so vier
prozent raus heute machen wir aber
kleiner imbiss lab genau deswegen machen
jetzt direkt sechs portionen und ich
teile die auch ganz gerne immer vorher
schon ein damit ich das später draußen
auch komplett ohne ausbaustopp und alles
machen kann was am besten jetzt schon
bisher vor portionieren und
dann zu schönen kugeln verarbeiten
einfach von außen nach innen
oder auf der arbeitsfläche und dann
fertig sie bisher mit olivenöl 1 und
dann können sie nämlich schon aufgehen
abgedeckt aufgehender trocknet nix ein
[Musik]
dann stehen die oberfläche noch mit
olivenöl ein bisschen einstreichen dann
denke ich das ganze mit einem pizza
blech ab und geht gleich raus kann den
grill vorheizen und dann nämlich noch
die restlichen zutaten vorbereiten
[Musik]
den tag habe ich jetzt mit rausgenommen
und lasst den hier einfach stehen der
geht hier jetzt wundervoll auf denn es
ist richtig schön warm hier und jetzt
muss ich erst mal den grill vorbereiten
das heißt ich habe hier auch meine pizza
stein schon aber der grill muss erstmal
aufheizen und ich schreibe jetzt was
wenn ihr hier nämlich so einen sack
holzkohle habt haben viele das problem
dass sie das nicht auf kriegen aber das
war so eine cat masche das heißt er ist
einfach da vorne praxis an der seite wo
man diese städtische sieht
der rückseite ist diese kette masche und
hier vorne müsst ihr den faden lösen und
können das einfach abziehen dann muss
man nicht schneiden
[Musik]
wenn auf reisen ist zwecklos das bringt
nichts den faden kriegt man hat
aufgerissen um eine sparsame aber mal
würde zeigen den hebel noch auf und dem
benutzer dann wird er weiter für was
anderes also danke rhein und ruhr an
[Musik]
schon immer schön verteilen und ihr seht
schon die kohle ist wirklich perfekt und
ich habe große und kleine stückchen und
einfach ausfüllen bis zu dieser unteren
erster linie dadurch dass sich diese
großen und kleinen stück gehabt
entzündet sie sich gleichmäßig wird
gleichmäßig warm der grill ist schön
heiß später jetzt einfach anzünden ich
nehme immer den ruf leiter dafür also
keine grillanzünder und kein spiritus
bitte auch sowieso beim big green egg
niemals denn das setzt sich dann alles
in der keramik festes vormonat und damen
jetzt hat sich das jetzt auf ich muss
auch sagen das gerät ist ganz günstig es
lohnt sich wirklich und seit ich deshalb
brauche ich meinen mann nicht mehr zum
grillanzünder aber mit sozusagen
das geht es alles ganz einfach
[Musik]
wenn er dann sagt 23 stellen entzündet
habe ich den grill einfach schließen ich
mache dann oben und unten immer den
deckel auf damit sauerstoff rein kommt
also ein bisschen entgegensetzt zum
hausbrand wenn es bei euch dahin brennt
ist da immer alle fenster und türen
schließen damit kein sauerstoff rein
kommt und das feuer eben erlischt und
hier brauchen wir sauerstoff deswegen
oben und unten eben schon auf machen ja
das geht jetzt hier ganz von alleine und
dann setze ich das hier gleich rein und
kann solange die anderen zutaten
vorbereiten nämlich zum einen die band
creme dann mache ich noch so eine
petersilien salsa und murat grad noch
spargel vom bauern klaus und ist richtig
und es dauert hier so ungefähr eine
halbe stunde ja ich setze das schon mal
rein
damit es gleich mit warm wird
habt ihr einfach in rust und einen
schönen pizza stein
[Musik]
denkt auch schon dran den grill
natürlich auf temperatur zu bringen weil
jetzt hat er gerade 600 jetzt muss ich
dir natürlich bisschen runter kühl und
dann so also pizzabacken ungefähr so bei
300 gerade in italien wenn sie schön
dünn ist meine wird wahrscheinlich nicht
ganz so dünn deswegen mache ich so
zwischen 230 und 250 grad der stein wir
jetzt schön warm das heißt ich muss hier
oben und unten den schacht ein bisschen
schließen und kann das hier dann gut
kontrollieren ok jetzt geht's zum belag
dafür nehme ich jetzt erst mal 400 km
und eine knoblauchzehe und salz und
pfeffer das wird erstmal die creme tier
selbst sozusagen die
tomatensoße
knoblauchzehe kommt hier rein und hab
ich in meine
fresse
hier draußen ist noch richtig windig da
haut sonst alles um
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das schmeckt jetzt mal gut da ist
nämlich genug knoblauch dran jetzt
gibt's noch mehr petersilien salzer also
eine so fertigung später auf die pizza
aber die kann ich auch vorbereiten so
lange der grill hier noch schön auf
temperatur kommt und dafür nehme ich
petersilie bisschen koriander etwas
olivenöl
rotweinessig ein bissle kreuzkümmel des
schon hier gemahlen und ein bisschen
knoblauch und den muss jetzt noch
waschen und es passiert jetzt bei uns
wieso von zauberhand denn ich habe hier
kein waschbecken ich strecke quasi die
ungewaschenen winzer aus dem bild so
da hat manchmal nur so ist ein moment
aber das funktioniert hervorragend und
dann kriege ich sie einfach gewaschen
wieder zurück
wahnsinn oder dafür könnte jetzt
entweder den stabmixer nehmen oder einen
blender und dann gebt ihr hier die
petersilie und den koriander die minze
reihen und bis letzter kleiner natürlich
koriander nämlich zu viel denn den mag
ich nicht so gern aber so ein bisschen
davon passt schon ein bisschen müsse
das macht schön frisch
jetzt so fiel dann etwas rotweinessig
und kreuzkümmel
salz und pfeffer
die knoblauchzehe shop so riesig da
nehme ich jetzt mal die hälfte
ich nehme erst mal ein viertel
und olivenöl und dann schön pürieren
[Musik]
dann haben wir jetzt schwarz salsa
gemüse muss ganz kurz vor schneiden ich
habe hier schon mal spargel der ist
geschält vom bauern klaus natürlich und
da habe ich jetzt einen spargel genommen
der von der qualität einfach sehr gut
ist der ist schön zart klimazone
spargelstange die einfach bisschen
dicker ist die ich jetzt verwenden würde
für zum beispiel im pfannkuchen und das
ist so einer days auch ganz gut wenn sie
nur mal so halbjahr ist es passt dann
auch ganz schön
so holzige enden hat gar nicht weil er
einfach schön frisch ist und den
schneide ich jetzt hier einfach in
schmale schöne scheiben
dann noch bis zu teenie dazu und denn
die frühlingszwiebel die kommt danach
erst drauf
[Musik]
ich nehme diese schöne zucchini durch
die mal an wie schön die ist diese
kleine baby zucchini
bisschen im garten
[Musik]
dann geht's los war mein tag ist
ordentlich aufgegangen und ich nehme
bezirk immer gern so eine pizza blech
etwas olivenöl
dann habe ich noch einen weichkäse
sondern französischen weiss käser den
honig vielleicht auch schon mal raus das
ist nämlich auch zum pizza belegen
und dann habe ich eigentlich alles ich
habe spargel zucchini meine schmandt
creme einem salzbad in weichkäse
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt die erste teig
kugel und die wird es hier schön
geöffnet und deswegen habe ich auch ganz
gerne diese pizza belächelte drehen sich
nämlich gut mit dann kann ich das ganz
gut machen und was jetzt gleich
verbraucht am besten zum rüberschieben
auf dem peter stein sondern torten
retter damit geht es am besten
unseren bisschen hartweizengrieß oder
maisgrieß so kann man nämlich gleich
testen ob die temperatur auf dem stein
stimmt also ob es vielleicht zu heiß ist
oder doch im zu kalt das zeige ich euch
gleich
also hier einfach schön öffnen
und bevor ich die jetzt belege
kommt das jetzt nämlich schön auf meinen
torten rette uns
wie lange kann ich schon mal testen ob
der pizza steingut ist das thema
vorsichtig kurz aufmachen dann öffnen
und so ein bisschen was drauf streuen
dann sehe ich schon ob der stein war
mist wenn jetzt hier der gries sofort
verbrennt dann ist er einfach noch zu
heiß da muss man ein bisschen
runterkühlen
passiert es wird bis hin zu schnell
dunkle deswegen muss ich den stein
herunter kühlen und das geht am besten
mit so einem feuchten geschirrtuch
[Musik]
dann könnte er nämlich gleich so 10 20
grad runter und dann ist er perfekt
dann habe ich jetzt hier den torten
retter jetzt auch schön gries drauf
liegt einfach weg
dann kann ich nämlich so ein bisschen
wählen dann seht ihr auch schon damit ja
noch ein bisschen raus dann ist nämlich
ganz schön runter schieben und das
bildet sich eine tolle kiste und das mag
ich mal ganz gerne
aber es ist halt so gut runter schieben
können
muss man richtig von allein runter
flutschen
ja und dann belege ich das jetzt hier
mit der schmandt creme gemüse und käse
und trüffel butter und passt er passt da
sag ich trüffel butter und salz ag
später drauf jetzt auch gar nicht zu
dick sondern schön bist normale schöne p
[Musik]
also wenn man sichergehen will dass der
stein nicht zu heiß wird kann man auch
diesen connector reinpacken es dann noch
mal so ein stein sozusagen aber dann
finde ich verlierer shop catalog ist
also deswegen macht es ruhig mit dem
tuch und dann einfach mal austesten
hallo nächste pizza
[Musik]
ich muss sagen so dass kids machen hier
draußen macht spaß und vor allem wenn
ich jetzt nur für gäste erwartet wobei
mir ist das ganze team dann einfach da
mache ich es einfach so dass ich dann
jetzt schon mal schauen wie lange
braucht die erste pizza gerade nur noch
ein paar minuten ich glaube ich könnte
auch noch ein bissel hitze drauf geben
und dann kann ich einfach schon mal
weitermachen und die pizzen belegen aber
auch nicht so lange stehen lassen und
dann ist es halt so dann ist das halt
direkt und es ist schön mit gleich heiß
gegessen direkt vom stein
[Musik]
egal
da die erste pizza sieht super aus
nehmt jetzt raus
muss schnell gehen
dann packe ich direkt die nächste
nämlich rein
ok
damit jetzt noch fertig gestellt nämlich
mit der grünen salsa und trüffel butter
und dann kann man gleich probieren
ich würde auch sagen dass wir jetzt
einfach mal alle aus dem team die jetzt
gerade hier so sind zusammentrommeln
utah und toga und dennis und yvonne
kommt auch dazu
wer lust hat keiner mehr hallo
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
also griffen butter noch drauf
aha
ariel
wir haben dich entdeckt
dass dabei auch vom luca
beluga
ok
sehr gut
danke ich bin jetzt aber gespannt und
nichts sagt das war so ein bisserl
inspiriert von meinem münchen besucht
und die schon ordentlich heiß gern
wie viele sind wir
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
ach ja noch die studenten
dann bedient euch mal
frühstück bevor das stück
ich habe eine freundin die belegt ihre
pizza immer ganz mehr drin weil die zwei
kinder sich sonst im streiten
fast mehr
davon
und er schätzt das kind gewesen gemerkt
hätte
das gemüse beeren salzen
aber so haben auch etwas macht ständer
opa kommt peter essen
was sagst du als sternekoch mit einem
super lecker und somit dem
eine gute alternative zu tomaten sind
noch sehr würzig und auch der käse so
dass man muss schon gucken dass man
überall auch von von dieser salsa haben
weil sonst fehlte bisher salz muss ich
sage
[Musik]
also probiert rezept gerne aus ich würde
sagen 'ich packe die pizza fertig bei
uns um das team und für diana in der
kamera da kann sie die kamera nämlich
auch gleich weglegen und dann könnt ihr
mir gerne mal schreiben was so eure
lieblings pizza kombination ist das muss
auch sagen ich probiere schon immer mal
was gern was neues auch mal aus aber was
ist euer standard was ihren standort
witterte immer geht los
herr geschockt und traurig lebte schon
die artischocke
harmonie artischocke zubereitet
das machen wir mal also macht's gut bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
ich finde es einfach
so gibt schild draußen am grill socket
schild jetzt sonne jetzt mal ein
bisschen musik es geht immer während des
drehs nett findet gema und willkür allem
aber zeigen welche die musik rein und
dann praktisch uns die pizza fertig
[Musik]